latest data shows covet 19 numbers are
on the rise again local labs also
noticing the increase in positive cases
joe muller spoke to health experts about
it he joins us from the strip with what
they have to say joe good afternoon
good afternoon christian as numbers
continue to rise nationally and here
locally in southern nevada experts say
these numbers could be much worse than
they are turning out to be because of
how many people are simply testing at
home
kovid 19 is still making the rounds the
latest southern nevada health district
data shows the seven-day moving average
is up to 286 cases a day as of may 15.
that is up from a few months ago when we
were seeing 78. hospitals are seeing an
increase but it is not stressing out the
system according to the nevada hospital
association isaac farrell from icylabs
this week
we've seen a big uptick we started to
see it last week
and now this week of the people we're
testing is about a 20 percent positive
rate so to me that's quite high southern
nevada health district communicable
disease manager kimberly franich says
almost all the cases are a subvariant of
the omicron strain and it is much more
transmissible she says due to more home
tests being available now the cases are
much higher than the data reflects many
of those people who are testing positive
aren't necessarily going in and getting
those pcr testing so we know that the
numbers that we have are severely
underreported
at least 50 percent
granite says the southern nevada health
district is keeping a close eye on these
numbers and they are prepared to open
more testing sites and longer hours if
they need to reporting live on the strip
john muller live local now